welcome to this video playing kitsune
gari kidzania gari from the US and let's
see what we get two goons how to know
the king's indian mmm I could I could
play something else so play the avocado
sister so I'm pretty good pretty good
system but not so not so on so popular
nowadays yeah he takes the fibers and in
fact a good line but people usually
don't go for that here we have a case
where black opted for for the simple
recapture usually they go queen a5
forgotten hard to continue I think it's
is it f form or e6
not sure but I have spent time in the
process that's always important okay so
he said he got this some pawn this extra
pawn here on d huh but it's of course a
rather weak bond how to continue though
it's not see this is D foursquare son is
rather annoying that term he's got that
yeah taking us probably not especially
great maybe play useful move with rupee
one the problem with this pond
configuration is with pawns on e 786 the
c8 bishops biting on the pond and if you
play you 65 the g7 bishop is dead you
should probably go for I thought to be
six bishop be something this is this i
didn't expect not saying that it is bad
but i didn't i didn't expect it okay how
to how to continue here not quite sure
what he's doing I could I could I'd like
to play Bishop Bishop to age six son
would be a would be helpful my queen
doesn't have have any any good spot
still what if I take it I can actually
take with the bishop don't like it yeah
but ruki one doesn't really fit well
with this okay if he takes with the
bishop i can play Bishop h4 and can we
have to the knight on d4 really was a an
annoying Pisa and I need some some
squares former pieces especially for the
Queen and this is why I went to went for
this okay maybe the bishop here
improving quincy tourism is one possible
square i'll be three and no i need to
exchange correctly here I don't think
I'm particularly yeah bad in this
position it's it's not clear to me I can
probably go to g3 and try to pick up the
e5 pawn we cannot take on c4 because of
Bishop g5 check
yeah it's not down at all clear well
this is interesting yeah maybe he wants
to take take now still I don't really
think that that this is sighs this is
too great I can I can play 95 for
instance this is a good movie on 95
intending 97 check him the problem is he
has this Bishop onda forages yeah nice
piece looking good Monty form but it
doesn't help in defense at all so let's
just if it was was my move 97 with just
made or win the Queen and I'm not quite
sure what here's what he can do against
it maybe play on can you play no I
thought maybe a desperado move like you
for but like I can just take with the
Queen and it's still excellent for white
yeah i think the exchange sac wasn't
wasn't sound at all no that's this is
interesting didn't see that move
hmm yeah if i move the Queen I'm losing
the night what a strange move maybe it
is a good move I can take its
everybody's got Queenie 7 and will be an
exchange up
amazing check yeah very very strange
resource check I didn't see that at all
and now black Itza is fine again hmm so
95 wasn't working amazing okay so what
is this position um yeah it's not a
particularly great but still no reason
to UM to to be desperate yeah the time
is of course a problem
yeah 22 seconds check time warning d 2 I
can play Roxy five yeah I probably
should be a should be and losing for me
the deep on is too strong I don't I
don't see your win at the moment for
black of it there should be something
yeah this is a bit passive huh but i
didn't i didn't see I didn't see a move
with the limited time able just he would
just promote ah resigns I had this
nightly to move really I didn't see it
at all now I mean the exchange sex still
still as bad for black button i cannot
play 95 I didn't see 92 might be five
was also good it was just just strange
that this is working but it is working
otherwise why would have simply one but
then now I need to check can get into
this rather uncomfortable end game it's
probably not not a loss or anything but
yeah here I considered a form but I
didn't didn't play it oops for him i
thoughti for would be able to be good
yeah the computer assesses this is quite
good for white due to this trick which I
of course I couldn't see in the time
this is really nice I cannot cannot go
this here and after capturing only get
the pawn because this is a rather
the bed or even rookie seven so it's not
helping this means that I get this pawn
yeah okay now this position only white
can win but it's probably still wrong
but yeah I'm around here I got I got
into trouble he got to act of here yeah
okay i know but what what should i do
taking help helped him i wanted to
activate the rookie on this look but
that it's simply too strong a porn on
the deform alright thanks for watching